good morning John go into the bookstore
to get Fault in Our Stars is is not
existing so January it's time for the
place to January time which
means this package is able to be open
I'm gonna do that now my sign you're
fine
Jai screw oh my god is it a good face it
makes nice doesn't it
[Music]
Johnna know that you're standing like 20
feet away from me right now no you can't
be here for this I can't say it to you
in person because you know we're
brothers I'm really proud of you I'm
really proud of the Fault in Our Stars
I'm really proud of what you've done
with this book every review has been
fantastic everyone has started everyone
on Amazon loves it and I love it you've
accomplished a really great thing here a
couple of announcements while I'm
waiting out here for you to finish your
phone call one if you bought the
audiobook from dftba records do not
watch the DVD before you read or listen
to the book because there are spoilers
in the DVD too while we're on tour we're
doing a thing called nerd cash where we
leave buttons bags of buttons in places
you can only find out about that by
following us on Twitter thank you to all
the people whose videos I used in this
video especially text artists who did an
amazing Fault in Our Stars text thingy
which I link to of course in the
description and thanks for Alex days
Forever Yours you've been listening to
the instrumental version and thank you
to everyone who is purchased and is
reading The Fault in their stars and
posting pictures of themselves on tumblr
with it John to be honest it's an honor
to be your brother it's an honor to be
on this tour with you and I'll see you
well actually I can see you right now
you right over there